The Joe Rogan Experience I wanted to
talk to you about this is a little bit
of a deviation but it's not really I
wanted to talk to you about theranos
because I am
[ __ ] completely obsessed with that
lady and her scam company dude did you
know that I was almost the chief medical
officer of that company
no
yeah dude so in 2006 my McKinsey office
which was in Palo Alto was on the same
was on Page Mill which was one street
over from where theranos was located so
theranos at the time was a super small
company
so a good friend of mine
his father-in-law was on the board and
knew Elizabeth Holmes very well he was
her professor at Stanford
and
the company was small at that time it's
like maybe 30 people there something
like that and he said look I you know I
want you my friend
um to potentially look at this company
and because they could really use a CFO
and he was in private Equity at the time
really smart guy
and to make long story short I got
introduced to Elizabeth so I went down
and had lunch with her one day did you
ever catch her talking in a real voice
you know it's so I don't remember I met
her later and she already had the fake
voice but I can't remember that day what
her voice was like I I wish I could
remember but you know it's like 15 years
ago right I would remember if it was
weird like I don't think I don't think
it was I think it might have been a talk
like this I would say what is going on
yeah yeah if you had throat cancer I
don't I don't what are you doing I I
think she was she must have been talking
to normal voice but here's what
interested me I sat down in the office
and she pulled out a black box that was
I don't know if it was called Edison at
the time or if it was the precursor to
what would become Edison
um Diagnostics is not something I knew a
ton about but you know I'd spent two
years at the NIH and I certainly
understand how chemical reagents work
and I understand how chemical assays
work and I know how for example and
Eliza works and Eliza is a type of
um assay that you do to measure
something but it requires a lot of
washing and rinsing and repeating and I
know that many biomarkers that are of
interest for example something like
insulin you know if you want to measure
a person's insulin level
you have to do these types of assays
right
so
I was saying to her you know Elizabeth I
don't understand how you could put a
drop of blood in here and get anything
out that's more interesting than glucose
hemoglobin sodium and potassium the
really simple things that can work you
know that can be measured off a drop of
blood
and she kind of gave me some answer and
I said well can I see the inside of the
box and she said absolutely not and I
said well I've signed an NDA you know I
had to sign an NDA to get in the
building so and she was like nope so
um I just decided I wasn't interested in
the company because I couldn't get sort
of straight answers from her so I ended
up not doing it so fast forward to 20
this was 2006. fast forward to 2015
she's now on the cover of Forbes
and
um and you're like well no no I I just I
remember one day saying to my wife
because she was on the cover of Forbes
and the company was valued a little over
nine billion dollars and I said to my
wife do you know how much we would be
worth if I had taken that job now and
she's like how much and I told her and
she's like good
and
I so I'm at the Vanity Fair Event in San
Francisco this by I didn't know it at
the time this was a week before the Wall
Street Journal article would fall John
cario's article that was the one that
kind of unraveled all of theranos in
October of 2015. and what how did he
figure it out how'd this one guy figure
out that it was all so I haven't read
his book Bad Blood
um but I saw the documentary so you know
that's like a poor man's version of it
but basically just interviewing people
who were formerly employees of the
company oh so they were being Spillers
yeah yeah and they were basically like
yeah this is a total scam oh my God and
so sure enough I'm at this reception
because she and she's the speaker of the
event so she's like it's a four-day
conference and she's the she's the one
everyone there is there a c so I'm I'm
sitting at the a table and I'm having a
cocktail and she walks up and she and I
said hey Elizabeth you probably don't
remember me she goes no I remember you
exactly and she remembered my name and
even remembered how I had been
introduced to her I was like really
Blown Away we exchanged pleasantries she
gave me her card
and then a week later it all unraveled
and it's really funny I still have the
card I should frame it yeah yeah yeah
um she must have known that the [ __ ] was
hitting no no she totally did yeah yeah
because the [ __ ] was hitting the fan six
months earlier
what does one do and it's not like you
can liquidate right like you if you're
worth nine billion dollars but it's all
stock and you know the product is
nonsense you can't even get out so it's
a private company so at best you know
she could have along the way been doing
secondaries off her take but oh so it
wasn't even yeah yeah I'm fascinated
that she wouldn't let you look into the
box because I guess if you looked into
the box you would immediately be able to
be I don't know that I would have let's
I don't want to overstate my credentials
I'm not a clinical chemist I I'm she
could have duped me I'm sure but she
didn't I mean and again we're under NDA
we're talking about me joining her
company as a chief medical officer like
right how are you not going to let me
see inside this freaking box like what
do you want how am I gonna do my job
does she have duped you though if she's
not technically
astute like she doesn't really
understand I don't know she could I mean
look she presumably duped people smarter
than me right I think she do this is
what drives me crazy I think she duped
people from the image I think they
wanted to believe they wanted to believe
that here's this female Wonder kind who
left Stanford at 19 years old dropped
out of school and figured out this
amazing technology and along the way
became at least until she got busted the
richest self-made woman ever
she was worth I think like her own four
and a half billion yeah crazy crazy
and she just faked it and one of the
ways she got busted was people from
college that she went to school with
were like why are you talking like that
like what's happening and then people
started hearing that that wasn't her
real voice and then people started like
they were rumors and murmurs there's so
many layers to that story oh man no
doubt yeah it's a fascinating one it
really is it's such an interesting story
so for you when all that was going down
that must have been incredibly sweet
because now you don't have to think man
I missed out on all that money yeah for
sure and I and I was also I felt a
little bit validated like okay it there
was a reason she didn't want to show me
the inside of the box right yeah yeah it
might have been empty it literally might
have been empty there was candy in there
it's a giant like little thing yeah dude
she got so many people she got Betsy
DeVos for like 100 million
and poor General Mattis think I didn't
have two nickels yeah corrupt together
when he gets out of the military he put
like a couple hundred K in or something
obscene for him yeah
[ __ ]
crazy whenever someone comes to me like
some guy came to me with some crazy I
mean I don't know if it's real so I
don't want to talk about it like say it
specifically but if it's true it sounds
like this guy's gonna revolutionize a
form of travel and so he's telling me
about this I was like Wow and then I
said to my business manager who's with
me at the time I go don't ever forget
about theranos whenever someone tells
you something the moment someone tells
me I go yeah when it happens I believe
you I'm I don't want to be involved in
any groundbreaking [ __ ] before it
actually especially in some area where
I'm completely ignorant and what am I
going to do just start going to school
try to figure out engineering
think of this guy as saying something
that's actually possible and plausible
no can't do it not interested buddy
[Laughter]
so for you though when it did come out
though there had to be like a a cool
feeling of satisfaction there had to be
a little something there well you're
like I mean the first person I called
was my buddy the guy who had introduced
me to her way back and I was like dude
what are the dinner conversations like
and he's like oh dude it's not good
because his father-in-law was still in
the believing Camp oh no oh yeah they
talk about him in the yeah oh [ __ ] so it
was so he got duped long after the The
Jig was up right yeah I I again I don't
know the details but it was it was I was
like man
[ __ ] it's good that we didn't do that
but watch the entire episode for free
only on Spotify